the previous head of the Air Force had
wanted to push the limit to improve
diversity
[Music]
instead the RAF ended up discriminating
against white men on his watch it is now
time for me to pass command of the royal
Air Force
to actually Marshal sir Rich Knighton
Marshall sir Mike wigston handed over
command earlier this month so it's been
left to the new boss to face the music
about a policy that prioritized pushing
women and ethnic minority recruits onto
training courses ahead of white men air
Chief Marshals Sir Richard Knighton said
the belief at the time was that this
practice demonstrated acceptable
positive action
we now know that it did not and I
apologize unreservedly to all those
affected
we accept that some men were
discriminated against
an inquiry was launched after Sky News
last year revealed the then head of
recruitment group Captain Lizzie Nichol
had resigned over what she deemed to be
an unlawful order the RAF has now
published the findings that prove she
was right
legal advice group Captain nickel sort
said that previous recruitment activity
to fast-track women and ethnic
minorities onto training courses had
been contrary to the equality act but
the head of recruitment still had to
resign to stop it happening again I've
just come out from a briefing in the
ministry of Defense with the new chief
of the air staff he talked us through
the content of the report he said it
makes pretty uncomfortable reading he
said the Air Force is determined to
learn lessons but he also said that
nobody is being held responsible for
what happened no one is facing
disciplinary action even though the RAF
broke the law
the defense secretary said the RAF had
made a significant error I also think
that the treatment of the officer who
raised concerns and her very genuine
worry is being ignored was something
that is needs to be looked at
considerably about why she was ignored
the former head of the Air Force has
admitted mistake cakes were made but
previously denied any unlawful activity
some of what you said in your opening
remarks implied that there were
different standards applied that there
was active discrimination against
people who you know
white men but that was that was that was
not the case
air Chief Marshall wigston may have
stepped down as head of the RAF
but he probably won't be able to step
back from The Fallout
Deborah Haynes Sky News